ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are live from an
undisclosed location in brooklyn new
york and we have a special guest
i don't know how we got him it's so
tough to get people now because
of covid you can't get anything go to
williams sonoma you try to get a pan
they don't have it in the store you got
to order it online
can't get any furniture can't get any
clothing everything's backed up because
of covet
the same thing with podcast guests
they're very very tough to get
right now but we have pulled every
string i i went to my people at caa
i went to everybody i went to every
connection i knew
i twisted every arm i greased every palm
and
finally finally uh it it it
came through uh we're very excited to
have this
man on the show uh ray kump hello thank
you for having me
thank you it was a process yeah no
look i mean when i found out from my
agent that you wanted to be on the show
um it took a moment to register oh right
and yeah
look we're old friends so why not yeah
there's a lot going on but we're all
friends
we're old friends so listen to this you
get my agent calls
me today he goes like this listen to
this right
anybody who's not in this business and
by the way if you're not good
don't be don't try to get into it but uh
anyone who's not in the business isn't
familiar with
how in many not in all cases but in many
cases
agents in matt they're just becoming
useless
so they don't really call you anymore
with like
you know like actionable intelligence
you know they always say like
things that can actually help your
career they call you with things that
they disguise as opportunities
so listen to this my agent calls me a
few hours ago and goes like this he goes
hey man how are you he's like i got ryan
on the phone too some other guy he's
like that's me and ryan on
i just auditioned for curb i thought
like they were telling me i got curb but
i was like oh great i'm so excited you
know
like i got ryan on the phone they're
like alright so we just want to go
through a couple opportunities if that's
okay with you i'm like oh yeah baby
i'm i'm in let's do it i'm ready i love
the show you know and
yeah so the other day uh we were talking
apparently lakeith
stanfeld seen you on rogan and he thinks
you're really funny now
uh there's there's probably nothing
really
to do but maybe you want to write
something with that in mind
he's the guy from what ben i get out
sorry to bother you
he's not okay he's always an established
guy okay cool but they go like this they
go maybe you want to write something
with that in mind i'm like you want me
to write a buddy cop
film for me and lakeith stanfeld i'm
like
what are you saying here so he's a fan
is he a fan of the show
he just saw me on rogan and thought i
was funny it's like dude that's
so that's millions of people this is
like the friend who's like yo you
you go past a girl you one day girl your
pen in high school
and she's like thanks and then your
other friend when you walked away goes
like you should try to [ __ ] her
yeah right but it's exactly right
then they go like this they go and
there's a guy at danny mcbride's company
not danny mcbride
there's a guy danny price company who
works in the documentary division
who's also a fan of you and he said to
us i don't think there's anything to do
right now with him but we
really like him and i go what is and
they go so we just want to like set some
time
next week to go over some more of these
opportunities i'm like
they're not opportunities i want you to
understand something tim uh
this is one of those moments when you
have to iron's hot you got to strike
okay there's no there's no time to
wiggle waggle about this
tom hanks his janitor
signed up for your patreon yeah that's
literally what it is
it's like these are not opportunities at
all they have
nothing to do look i i've never
understood
uh that side of the business and they
understood me
yeah but uh look it's like calling me
and going
listen sir sharon stone is drinking
heavily she's into q and on and thinks
you're great
we don't know if there's anything there
yet but we just think we should explore
it later on it's like
this is like saying look look all right
well i wanna
hear something um
kevin spacey he's just lost custody of
his children
this is a big opportunity like this is
people spiraling
it's not it's not it's people who's on
the career now
you're seeing you on the way down it's
it's it's one of our favorite
phrases really it's less than nothing
you know what i mean it's absolutely so
call someone to just say hey
somebody famous thinks you're funny i'm
like a lot of people do who cares
unless there's something to be done that
was like eight years ago when you got
excited about that yeah i was like
yeah i'm like dude i got bills to pay i
want to there's things i want to do that
it requires money like
creatively it would be one thing if they
were like hey
uh you know they've got a real great
idea why don't you hear them out
or they think you could be plugged into
something or there's something going on
but to just say hey they saw you on
rogan
and they think you're funny and they
want to i don't think they said like he
said if he wants to talk to me which i'm
like
great right like i'm like i'll talk to
anyone right that's what i do
i think it'd be so funny if like i sit
down with him and he's like hey man why
don't you put candace
on there i'm like oh this is this is
what we had to get caa involved
just tweeted me like everyone else to go
[ __ ] myself
he was like i think ken's had a lot of
great ideas
i can't say that he's like i want to
thank you
for exposing me to candace oh that's who
i now love
um so it's just we're at a point now
where it's like the level of insanity
you get to the point i was kind of
addicted to them on the fog right
they were like we want to set a time to
talk about some opportunities i said if
we have real opportunities and not
like some crazy idea like some crazy
like non-specific hey why don't you
write a pilot for you and lakeith
stanfeld
you know on spec it's like yeah guys if
there's real opportunities let's discuss
it because the reality is it's like
there's you don't start writing the
pilot you this is what you always want
from your thing until
the money's changed hands the whole
thing
is that this is in lieu of
there's just no good news right which is
fine right because there hasn't been any
in years
just call with that like i'd respect
that just call and go
so you didn't so the royal edition for
in curb was like a plumber
they go they're going another way
they're going another way on that i'm
like of course they are
also i don't know if a casting director
is going to look at my twitter and go
yeah this guy was on a podcast with alex
jones yeah kenneth someone's on we don't
want to
we don't need that smoke we don't need
that heat
who needs that smoke what is there's no
other fat guy to play a plumber
we gotta get this guy for what you know
so i don't know i just have no i would
respect that if they were like listen
there's just nothing going on
it's just like when i used to work
retail and selling cameras and everybody
like when it was slow
the boss would be like i just watched
launches i want you to go through all
the old sales
people you sold cameras to a couple of
years ago and try to sell them
another camera it's just such a crazy
idea because i know sales and i know
that like when you have somebody there's
a mortgage it's like maybe the mortgage
is going
to like adjust or maybe circumstances
have changed
it's such a nothing could be a colder
sale than calling a guy that bought a
camera three years ago you know
you're like hey how's that how's that
doing how's that nikon doing
that thing i told you break yet how are
you feeling
you want to re-up why don't you come
down to the store we got some new models
how's that cannon treating you good it's
just
let me be honest with you i got a coke
problem yeah
i got to be real honest with you i need
70 which is the commission on this 8
000 camera that i sell you i will make
seventy dollars
and i need it or i'm gonna get my head
busted in
when i walk out of here so please come
down here and look at these cameras
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's so crazy and i think these agents
are all usually rich kids because who
would ever get into the business of
selling clowns no one that needed money
there's no like what's the kind of thing
also uh where like
it's one of those jobs where you could
be float like you need someone to float
you
for a while because they don't make
money the first few years no they're
they're like
uh you know they work on somebody's desk
yeah you know their parents are just
happy they're not you know
like you know in jail so they're like
usually it's the black sheep
of a wealthier family where it's like my
brother is at johns hopkins medical
center
you know my sisters works at a big ad
agency my other brother works at goldman
and i work at
wme because i you know obviously i'm not
going to be a tour guide like tim dillon
my aunt by the way she sent me like
little presents which is nice aunt donna
yeah
she sent me a a present for my christmas
tree
and it was the the greyhound tour bus
from new york city
and it just kind of rubbed me a weird
way yeah like
she's trying to take the piss yeah it's
almost like no matter who you are
yes that's exactly what it felt like
that's what it felt like was just a
double decker bus like basically when i
think of you i don't think of a range
rover i think of a dirty bus
you could run as far as you can run as
fast and as far as you want
but when you look back you're going to
be smelling bus fumes pig
that's what it felt like i'm like why
would i it's like giving a
recovering heroin addict an ornament of
a needle you know like here put this
syringe on the tree
once yeah only ever one step away yeah
yeah it was just such a weird
game well she you've always i look she's
very nice to me when i see her but you
i've always observed a certain level of
uh when the kids say salt it's just she
likes me
she's like she just remembers when i was
a drug addict sure she puts a little
salt on it yeah she remembers when i was
a drug addict and it's like
you know what do you want me to do yeah
you know
you got to go back and [ __ ] i'm sorry
i stole from your house
i didn't never stop but i was like i
think it's just the idea that like she's
like
you know trying to do the right thing
it's not it was nice that she sent the
ornament i just i go i say to myself i
go wait a minute
right she also sent me a conspiracy
board game and i was like what the [ __ ]
is this
what what has this worked his game even
look at it i didn't even look at it it
was just a conspiracy board game and i'm
like is this what we're doing
how about no presence was it just like a
mr potato head but it's kennedy
yeah you just keep hitting it i don't
know what it is but it's just like
it's a fun like conspiracy board and
it's like
that's not what we're doing here david
dobrik by the way we talked about this
talk about puzzles and games
david delbert came up with a game called
a 100 000 puzzle
he sold 17 000 of them in an hour
and people that buy the game can win up
to a hundred thousand dollars he didn't
sell a board he's he's selling gambling
he's just selling lotto tickets you made
a great point he really is like the
willy wonka for poor people
come with me and you'll see
i mean like give like i'll give you does
he give him porsches or something
he shows up with lambos occasionally
yeah look
i don't even know if he's a good guy
here's the thing it's the last thing you
want to give to someone who isn't
financially stable
and like financially literate with money
like like someone who's actually like in
the grips of poverty there's things you
have to work really seriously
yeah do you think they let them keep the
cars like right after the cameras are
off somebody comes in and takes the car
and the guy's like what they go you knew
what this was
you know what do you think you're being
given here's your appearance yeah yeah
he was 250 dollars but there's something
funny about like
this whole thing whether it's him or
jeffree star and i've talked about it on
the show before
this idea of youtube philanthropy like
these guys
and the way that they are like a lot of
they they're just like
hey i'll hit your venmo and it's so sad
watching people on twitter be like
listen you know
my wife is out of work she just had an
operation i've covered i can't really
and it's so sad they're like tweeting at
these big people to pay their bills it's
[ __ ]
terrible and what's so sad is there's
like i'll see that but
also in that same fee people i knew from
comedy going
hey me my roommate really we lost our
waitressing job sort of and
we we really use help with the rent it's
just like
it's just a stacking of like because
yeah you can't vet these people so it's
just like no i mean that's
why it's so devastating to
watch and sad and it's also like a lot
of these people no one quite knows why
they have money
like nobody knows why david dope like we
all know why but nobody
know like i'm confused right as to why
he has
the amount of money he does yeah but he
probably doesn't
no he does how much money does he have
what are 10 million or something right
oh so
10 million is not enough to be giving
away lambos though well they spot
companies sponsor and then they get they
buy the car well that's what this is
okay that's my point yeah what does he
have
you have 15 million she's a lamb he's a
lambo he's a lambo salesman
you sell slam you're a lambo advertiser
and listen good for
whatever but he made the money you know
he gets a lot of views
and stuff like that he's not looking but
you watch it and you go i don't i
i don't get it but it's not for me to
get here's the thing when
i don't hate the guy it's a good grift
whatever
but you know he's bringing more
positivity into the world that would be
otherwise i don't know if he is
it's just it's just weird it's it's it's
it's it's always this weird grift where
it's just like who's just actually
helping you probably
like a lot of people who get lotto like
when they wouldn't bake and just
completely [ __ ] up there's a certain
amount of success which i'll probably
never reach where you just have to start
saying things like
look under your seat like there's a
certain amount of money where people
just expect you to give them things
no matter what they're like okay i'm
gonna go get a free like water fan
if i if i sit through uh two hours of
oprah
like that was a big thing oprah started
it like look under your seat
then ellen did it and they give
everybody like there's just a certain
amount of money wherever you whenever
you hit that amount of money people
expect you to just walk around
and give them [ __ ] yeah this is kind of
thing you should do when you're a
criminal right
like a legit like mob boss yeah like
right you're just buying loyalty from
people
ellen should have given those cars to
her staff who she beat the [ __ ] out
yeah give them to the people that are
genuinely hurting people
yeah yeah and it's always you look at
people in the audience at eleanor oprah
and you go there couldn't be anyone less
deserving
than these middle class pieces of [ __ ]
upper middle class
have nothing to do but watch a
television when i was broke
i there was nothing less important than
going to watch a
tv taping right like the idea that like
anyone in that position needs anything
other than more work
like it should be look under your desk
there's more work for you to do
don't come back to this [ __ ] studio
to watch me interview
kirsten bell kristen bell or whoever
yeah the [ __ ] ellen's talking to
but yeah it's interesting the dobrik
game what did you find anything about it
it's it's
how much he won so he profited about 350
000.
see he made 350 grand but yeah but a lot
of it's a lot of games to sell in an
hour that's why we need a product right
we can't keep [ __ ] right
entertainment man
you you know [ __ ] you could you could
really go scratch
that what about something you could [ __ ]
you know i'm listening
like a furby that like because the
flashlight was too big and it's just too
gross
it doesn't look like a living thing you
need like a like a free or own version
of a furby
like but it's like maybe uh you know a
face
like a non what about a furby with a
very small mouth for pedophiles
look i mean it's better if they're doing
that than if you're you know with tis
and that's exactly what we'll say sure
like a
small mouth for a pedophile
to face [ __ ] why are you pushing back i
just don't know if we should lead with
that
obviously look pedophiles are nothing
else resourceful
they'll figure it out like they'll share
it on there before
i don't want them to understand i don't
know but we do because we don't want
them to [ __ ] the actual kids
fine but fine but i don't know if we
need to like come out
in the advertising in the press
conference and so let's just say it's a
child's doll but for a million other
things
the dildos that women use are massagers
right right sure yeah this is
it to practice if your child falls in
the pool giving him
giving him uh chest compressions and
mouth to mouth
this is this is problematic this is
complicated
my agent calls me he's like lakeith
stanfeld
sees you're a pedophile dog and he
thinks it's great
now he doesn't want to go into business
with you immediately but
just keep in mind that lakeith stanfeld
thinks you're a pedophile doll it's
great oh you guys been paying for me
oh [ __ ] yes that's right
somebody at danny mcbride's company who
is a pedophile
is really likes it doesn't want to say
who it is they sent us a message
through discord that they really like to
doll i mean could
yeah i don't even want to like you know
keep this going but like
you could have a thing where like
probably only kids would wear it so it's
not good but
like would it be a [ __ ] thing that
you could wear but also [ __ ]
but then it would just be the thing that
kids were in high schools i mean let me
get in trouble for it
yeah we don't want to get in trouble
those bracelets the kids used to
there's a little snap bracelets the
number of snapchats
yeah where you would snap it on your
wrist like you remember ben
wow because we got cut because it's a
metal thing in there
and they were like yeah and then there
were pogs i had pogs
i had o.j uh o.j slammer was your
simpsons slammer yeah
wow like keep oj out of the slammer or
something
and the back of it had a picture like an
engraving of a gun through his phone
and i remember more recently was the
fidget spinner i never had those
i didn't care but apparently they were
like a thing and then now they're
nothing
no they're nothing yeah like for like a
year there everyone was claiming to be
like
ocd maniac who like had to like [ __ ]
the whole time be honking 15 different
things
right you seen these advanced fidget
spinners they have like knobs and like
rounds and gears
these youtubers go i like this i have to
fiddle with things
like it's i love it thinking you could
show somebody a picture like you go
go back in history you show somebody a
picture of the future you see all these
people fidgeting with all these things
like oh what are all these gadgets
it's like oh nothing they're just
they're just for something
for people to do that are on too many
ssris to get their dick cards so they
just want to play with a [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] what is going on with
bitcoin you know about bitcoin
you're a financial analyst all right and
i know what i know about bitcoins when
it seems like it's going
high i don't know i know as much as i
knew five years ago which is
it's nothing it's [ __ ] raise a
bitcoin hater
what if this is a controversial
statement i think it's possible
it could grow over time into a thing
that people use but no one's really
using it yet
and again i don't have all the numbers
if you're some bitcoin nerd out there
and you're going to tell me but i've had
people who hate tweeting me
for years now because i haven't been up
on bitcoin for the old show
and going back like why don't you like
bitcoin it's going to go up and with it
it drops and it drops and it drops and
the same people
or you don't believe it's look it's a
bubble
now can these blockchain currencies work
yeah maybe like you know people
if they get adopted and they don't get
you know uh get the kibosh from the fed
and all that
you know if the banks don't keep them
out you know by that time the banks get
you know actually allow them if they do
they're gonna actually be central you're
going to get so much hate from that
and not not only because i am starting a
cryptocurrency with david dobrik
should david dobrik start his own
bitcoin
how great would it be if he just
literally one of the youtubers started
issuing currencies
like just pay with doughbox just pay
with doughbots
he goes to like the most like
economically depressed yeah yeah
he's like we give you a million dollars
yeah we're going i'm going to compton
and i'm handing out my new currency doe
box
if you're [ __ ] line up right after you
get your covid test which is fake
not covered but the test is fake come
and get doughbox
and we'll see i mean that would be great
if like let's keep the grip going
go move into other things move into
bigger arenas
like yeah like like currency arbitrage
why don't we just
somehow get you installed in a foreign
government
and like literally taking it but because
of the way i look it would have to be
like the shittiest foreign governments
like ireland like
the only government where i could
literally probably assimilate get into
and they're so dumb over there that i
could get like did you think we're gonna
make you the king of england
does ireland even have a cia no yeah
they have like guys who would throw like
literally just have cocktails of the
cops they have guys that just like
like like just literally like light
protestant baby strollers on fire
that's their version of the cia but it's
like that's the only government i could
probably get into
hello i'm patio flanagan my name is
patio flanagan i'm the new senator from
derry
i'll tell you a few things about this
country i believe in the future of
ireland
i believe in a free ireland i believe in
a free ireland
i believe that that we have to we have
to fight for the church of rome
what i mean even if it's not you but we
do
is there an angle we can get with the
politician no
why not why well level although
we start small but you need like a
low-level senator oh so listen to this
you're going to love this i'm first of
all i'm in new york right now and the
reason that i'm in new york
is because a re a seafood restaurant
opened i've told you about artie's fish
south shore fish yeah now we've never
went we never had
got a chance we went to other ones near
there but yeah artie's closed
i was very depressed you know how much i
like restaurants
yeah and you know i don't really have a
family you know
not that you like right so i love
restaurants
so like i was like let's go and i did
get to see my mother through the window
the mental institution which was lovely
which was very nice
you know it was a nice kind of visit i
just it was like sorry trump lost she
was like i know it's bad i'm like
she goes i hope the new guy keeps giving
me a stipend
she goes trump gave me 1200 and it went
into my account i hope the new guy gives
me a stipend and i'm like well i hope so
too
i hope for your sake and everyone else
is sick i i also hope so
so we go to artie's because they
contacted me on instagram they're like
we're back and we're doing fish and i'm
like man let's just get on a plane and
come here which i did there's no
quarantine there's no nothing i mean
everybody's like there's there's i guess
is this this thing that the media is
doing to scare people that which i get
because i guess they don't want people
to travel but like
they're putting all this information out
there's like there's checkpoints at the
bridges and tunnels and the military's
in the airports it's like
there's none of that okay yeah i don't
even know but i mean there's none of it
but what would they do anyway tell you
to go home
like tell you to go go quarantine
okay that's a great point
sean what the hell are you doing i i
don't know i'm getting pizza
you go on home just a big military guy
you don't get sick boy
you stupid [ __ ] sir yes sir i will go
home
spider-man's gone to the air yeah
i'm not powerless the empire endures
just screaming it's like who is this who
did you hire
um so we're sitting in artie's today
alfonse
d'amato walks in 82 year old
senator from the town i grew up in
island park
he's from island park he's from island
park he's from brooklyn he lived in
island park
the motto's like read can you on mike
read a little bit about the motto set
this up for people because it is
truly amazing okay so d'amato was of
italian ancestry it was born in brooklyn
and raised on long island in the small
village of island park
which is great he was the last
republican senator for
new york from 1981 to 1999.
um the only charity he is a part of is
the poker players alliance
it's a non-profit organization set up to
help protect and fight for the rights of
poker players in the united states
it's a lobby for the online poker yeah
yeah so
the charity oh please tell us the book
tell us to ben come here and tell us the
title
find the title of his book and then tell
us the title tomorrow's book and then
we'll talk about the motto
because the lunch was amazing but you
gotta this is
if you if if you didn't learn enough
about him by just and
shout out to him i might see him again
at this restaurant i'm not trying to
make things weird
but the name of the book he wrote is
absolutely perfect
the name of the book is power pasta and
politics
the word according to the world
according to senator aldomato look at
this
look at that right he looks like he's
like
he's like he's an alzheimer's so listen
to this he hates trump
he goes like this right he sits down
he's talking to the owner of the
restaurant he goes
listen you guys you know why he lost
this election he goes you got giuliani
in there giuliani's going over ukraine
hiring a bunch of crooks he goes
giuliani's a snake he goes i made
giuliani i put giuliani on he goes
giuliani's got no loyalty to anybody but
himself but himself
and he goes the guy's a scumbag and he
goes trump saws with scumbag he goes you
don't think trump's cheated on
everything
motto goes trump doesn't pay any of his
[ __ ] workers and the guy that owns a
restaurant goes
yeah he owed my buddy 80 grand he only
gave him 60. the mother was like you're
lucky he got 60.
he used to have to sue him to get money
and then it was so funny because i'm
sitting there with ben and we're
listening this whole thing and i'm like
ben don't you get it now where i don't
get invested in any of this [ __ ]
emotionally because this is just they're
all criminals like the motto's are
criminal
the motto's a criminal like giuliani who
prosecuted the mob is like hiring
mobsters to like help trump like they're
all full of [ __ ]
the whole thing's a grift and like it's
just so funny listening to motto talk
because anyone from new york who knew
trump knew he wasn't
like to say that donald trump cares
about the working man is like saying tim
dillon cares about the american people
it's hilarious my uncle's telling me
that like over thanksgiving dinner when
i was 10 about trump yeah before he was
even like a guy
yeah it was a known thing forever he has
no empathy the guy doesn't care at all
but it was so funny how just just uh the
motto unloading on giuliani for the
majority of the lunch i mean
look what did giuliani even do on 911
that's what i'm confused about how did
he become america's mayor
i think he was he digging people out of
the ground zero he stood there and i
think he was the mayor
i mean he i mean he was um he was he
performed his mayoral duties
and he was you know he maybe gave a few
i don't remember any giuliani speech i
remember the famous bush thing yeah
where he got on the
microphone and he was like we're gonna
find the people who did this
i'm just saying this guy's gotta he look
he fell far from grace but he was built
up so hard
after 9 11. well he did a good job with
new york i think yeah
beginning yeah and and there was a lot
of reasons new york cleaned itself up
you know the infusion of foreign you
know not foreign but but capital disney
world all that [ __ ] you know may
change new york as a city but like the
economy got better the economy and 90s
just got better anyway
people remember um but giuliani
certainly should get some credit for
that because he did do a lot
of of good things for the city of new
york at the time but then he just has
become
a a goon and then you see
that this is who he was the whole time
it's just a goon
remember when he ran for president it
was like it was absurd at that point
that was when you realized
he wasn't like as freezing about it but
he was just inept that was when he first
started taking the armor
when he's just oh he's not good at this
like he's just he kept bringing up 911
everything
every question was 911. he's like well i
was from a
i ran a city there was attack i allowed
al qaeda to destroy the soul of my city
he's like listen to me
bernard carrick and the saudi government
wired those buildings
and i sat there and i didn't say a
goddamn thing
do you have any idea what that's like
going to bed every night with the deaths
of 3 000 plus people on your hands
he got like [ __ ] because like you know
apparently firefighters hate him
because uh there were there was
something where they wanted to like
so at one point and there was day two or
three f911
like they realized there's a river of
molten gold under like tower 7 or some
[ __ ]
into the rubble what a goddamn hellhole
this country is we keep going and so
giuliani goes we have to like you know
secure this i guess we can't have the
gold will swim away
so he pulls people off of like looking
for like firefighters bodies and victims
and all you should
go you have to go i don't know
collecting molten gold with like
pale i don't know what they did
but they hate the they say from lord of
the rings
he's like listen you must find the river
of gold
it's like my brother is in that building
he's gone
nothing to be done but there's a river
of gold
coursing through the veins of this city
and you gotta find it
what a sick society that says
that's america's mayor that's what he
did right you're like what did giuliani
do he directed the effort
of the fire department to find the river
of gold
that's that should be a children's book
rudy julie 911 in the river of gold it's
like a weird harry potter book
rudy giuliani in the river of gold
what a [ __ ] creepy [ __ ]
dude i mean that is hilarious
yeah he just never he just but
but d'amato was unloading on him on lun
uh at lunch today
yeah he's like and then he got mad at
jimmy hayes who was the steakhouse
across the street he's like
that [ __ ] d'amato goes like go in
there with a gift card it's not working
jimmy's like giving me [ __ ] he's like
that cocksucker's sitting there drunk
he's sitting there drunk and jimmy does
like get drunk and just sit at the bar
and yell and [ __ ] and like
he said jamaat was like i've been going
there 40 [ __ ] years this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
whatever we'll go back to this
restaurant tomorrow and eat and it's so
good everyone go there southwest virgin
island park
and then listen if nobody if i can't
ever go again i i at least i had this
where did you guys have
lobster oh we went all out we got tuna
tartare and buffalo calamari and the
tuna tidbits and swordfish and seoul and
i mean we just
it was really good i mean we're staying
at a dump rosemalo eating
swordfish oh seems kind of lame
yeah it was good that was good just
seems like uh he's trying to you know
guys 82 he had covered two weeks ago
what's with all these people
is it's you're all just getting covered
eating fish i don't know i don't know
what they're doing they don't give a
[ __ ]
my friend michael has covered him like
he's doing it does anyone die from this
anymore
i don't think so i gotta be honest i
don't think i i don't think so there's
always a freak cake there's always like
a thing that happens like my aunt donna
collects tragedies right so she'll be
like she's always at the ready with like
some like well one guy turned blue
like i don't want to be insensitive but
i mean do you think this year
is it kind of a gimme for people whose
kids died of an overdose
what do you mean like we'll just tell
people with coping
freak cases oh yeah but that's got to be
horrible if they don't believe you like
like i'm like yeah you know um
john lost his fight with covid you go
covert
he's 24 years old it can affect young
people it can affect young people you
know it was shocking for us
and uh it was very you're like where did
he die
jail died in jail of govitta
nobody's like it's like somebody being
like honey honey died of color
25. yeah you're watching news it can
happen
it can happen you know it was just he
started to have all these weird symptoms
and lesions on his forearms and wrists
and uh you know he started stealing all
of our
money is that parkour yes it's one of
these new symptoms you have where the
kids start stealing your money
and accusing you of molesting them
always sweating
cold you were sweating you're saying i i
know what you did to me you touched me
you let
people touch me like it was weird
comfort
all of these odd symptoms but it's just
so funny when you're listening to
d'amato
and then uh you're listening to trash
all these people just talking like
really kind of that
accurately about his perceptions about
things whether they're right or wrong
and
he was also trashing biden he's like
they got by not tape
telling the council of foreign relations
that he's in the ukraine
his son's getting a lot of money because
you know cfr it's like real prestigious
you get in there you got to spend all
this money
he's doing all things but i mean he gets
it man he's wrong he's not wrong about
anything he got it and i was
ben was hearing and i'm like that's
politics in america
you want to know what it is you might
not like it you might want it to be
something else
maybe one day it will be i'm not telling
anyone not to organize
go force your floor vote for medicare
for all do whatever you want to do
but at the moment as it stands politics
in america it's a goon squad do you
think the cfr didn't back in the day
didn't [ __ ] with him
didn't like reach out to aldo i don't
know i think he was probably a guy that
they [ __ ] lied he's a criminal
yeah these are all criminals i mean like
these people
politics is is crime it's like it's
legalized bribery and corruption it's
what it is
it's like political parties used to
literally be they they ran gangs and
they ranked yeah
yeah so i mean it's just like this is
who these people are the direct
descendants of
in in every meaningful way and you know
you can hear that when they're at lunch
and just the way he's 82 it's so funny
because this [ __ ] i go in there
with a gift card
and you know like jimmy's being like
this [ __ ] tried to rob me
you know like on the other side it's
just
this has already been used yeah no it
has and keep running it like that
he's running he's just trying to get a
scam tomorrow's trying to get a scam
trying to get a few free stakes that's
really all that come politics in america
comes down to a few free stakes
can you get a few pieces of meat on the
arm i mean can you imagine how much
how much better it tastes than when you
[ __ ] like put your wallet out like
just getting
getting like someone the grip yeah it
just tastes like i want to go back just
for a minute to 9 11 the funny and i've
told this anecdote on the show before
but the funniest thing i ever saw in
like three years of
doing uh leading tours in new york city
like on and off for three years on a
double-decker bus
there was this guy named frank he was
like this kind of intense guy but not
like a conspiracy guy right
never like you know we smoke bots and
[ __ ] good dude
never really like did tours never really
got complaints
he just got really he just like
got really [ __ ] like heated one day
when and i never i was taking his bus
because i was just sitting on the bus to
deadhead
to where i was taking a subway back to
my house he was just doing like this you
know downtown route and i lived in
brooklyn at the time
and i was sitting there and he goes
somebody on the bus goes
uh you know the fire you know man the
fire department they were all heroes you
know running in those buildings and he
goes
franco's that's what you think he goes i
was there
he goes those firemen were cowards they
were running out of those buildings
because they didn't save anybody they
he goes to cops to farm and they were
cowards they were crying they were
running away
and the faces of the people were so
disturbed by how matter-of-fact he was
he's like i saw it
because he was not characteristic for
him to flip out like this yeah he
literally
saw it or believed he saw it like he was
like i saw it the cowards they ran out
of those buildings
they didn't go anywhere nearer they
could have been running out as they were
collapsing yeah
he gonna say he goes they didn't go
anywhere near those but i just never
seen someone just flip so quickly
it was just [ __ ] phenomenal everybody
we're
here in the new studio and we're talking
about
the ridge wallet
if you want me advertising your product
do we have an
email for the people that want me to
advertise their product the tim dillon
show
gmail.com hey if you want me
to get behind your business endeavor go
to the timdillian show
gmail.com if you want to get into big
leagues
if you want to get into big leagues
spend money to make money
understand rich wallet did they're still
at the top of the charts
the ridge is a minimal front pocket
wallet can you keep it in your back
pocket
sure but it's designed for the front
it designed it's designed to streamline
what you carry every day
so instead of having a bunch of
useless clutter in your wallet you get
a credit card maybe a debit card a
business card of your lawyer
somebody very close to you that you need
maybe
cash a little bit minimal amount crisp
bills
put them in front pocket good
two go
there's a lifetime warranty if you love
it and free returns if you don't
it comes in titanium carbon fiber
aluminum or as they say in the uk
aluminium
and over a dozen different styles and
colors
how long have we been working with ridge
about a year now
we've been working with ridge wallet
for a very long time and it is because
it's quality you understand that
because of the quality
i've never seen a rich wallet i've never
held one
i don't know what they are i i've never
been in a room with one i don't
i don't know what it is i don't and i
think i've done a very good job selling
it
having no familiarity with the physical
form of it
i've just i don't i don't know what it
is you have one
i do take yours out
i don't like this
it comes in titanium do we still have to
send the ads to the people
uh yeah yeah we do yeah
well they're not gonna like that no
probably not
why we can't even have fun anymore with
the ads yeah
it's like stupid take it out again i do
like it
it's a joke i'm trying to be funny and
now this
everybody's going to war with our funny
well then don't buy the products should
i just tell people that
don't buy them yeah i don't know what to
do
this is great you could fit more in it
than you'd think
look at that you got a bunch of stuff
you got a bunch of cards
what's that eat well from westin
that's a call what is that it's a hotel
card
you're cheating on your wife oh that's
your wife had to stay there because your
brother
is covered correct congrats
the westin huh really springing for it
boy was target booked
anyway
let me do the bits please just i'm
asking you
i'm telling you right now to let me do
the bits
because i know what's funny and what
works and i just feel like
for far too long i'm doubted
and people don't respect me
but if you want me to really get
involved with your
your product let's get involved
ridge dot com slash tim tim
ridge dot com slash tim use code tim
link in description so i've never done
this podcast but i know this guy
i know this show greg carlwood who does
the higher side chats i've listened to
it
he has very good discussions on there if
you're in the conspiracy world or you're
into it
he goes into everything i've listened to
he had a great episode about underground
military bases
underground tunnels that a friend of
mine sent to me
i am i'm into this show legitimately i
think it's good
um so if you're into the whitney webb
stuff that i have on
or if the graham hancock stuff that
rogan has on if you're into any of the
crazier wacko stuff like david ike which
can be very funny
um hundreds of interviews at the higher
side chats
or wherever you get your podcast this
guy i don't know his backstory greg
karlwood
but that's his name right greg carlwood
i believe so yeah
it's like coast to coast am but it's a
little bolder
he's got a great interview style and
he really lets people talk and i mean
they do it everything dude i'm talking
about mk ultra false flags
secret societies alien moon basis hollow
earth multi-dimensional intelligence
the controlled demolition of the
american economy
deemed deep state pot operations the
wealth child banking empire tesla
technology
rockefeller medicine the coveted 1984
agenda
it's just here how to live your best
life despite the never-ending scams and
schemes of the nefarious elite
he he really does go in all of it so if
you're if you're
it's a great show to fire up a joint
listen to go to the highersidechats.com
to sign up
use coupon code tim dillon for a free
month of the higher side chats
um the higher side chats encourages
people to hear from the counterculture
scholars authors doctors
and interested characters that don't
have a voice in the mainstream and see
how their perspective and research
stands up
i like a show like this because what he
does is he gives everyone a hearing
even if the conspiracy seems um
implausible
or crazy he's a very good interviewer he
gives everyone a hearing you might be
listening to it going this [ __ ]
is nuts but
it's still he gives everyone a hearing
and i've listened to a few of the
episodes that i've really enjoyed
doesn't mean i can
agree with everything that's being said
or i even think it's correct i just
think that
it is a good show and i think there
there needs to be shows like this all
over the place
and um he really is interesting stuff he
has
the people come on and talk about the
occult people come on talk about aliens
it's really just all the counterculture
stuff so i i
would tell you to go to this show go to
the highersidechats.com to sign up
thehiresidechats.com
to sign up and you will get
a lot of different opportunities to
you know satiate your hunger for
conspiracy type of content in in in
vastly different ways
so you'll have people talking about the
economy
and then you'll have people talking
about you know health policy and
medicine
you'll have people talking about
technology you'll have people talking
about underground bases
it goes all over the place and i i will
put on an episode of his
um when i'm on a plane going somewhere
so go to the highersidechats.com to sign
up
it was phenomenal but i'm glad i came
across the country the new york city now
we came into the city
the the the city now has
outdoor dining in buildings they've
built
wood and plastic like sheds like sheds
like horse stalls that look like they're
part of a stable like it looks like
there's things that like when you sell
christmas trees out of
it's the strangest it is exactly what it
looks like
it's so odd and then they have these big
tents like in long island some people
have these tents and i go
what the [ __ ] going on like how is it
not
transmissible in a tent or in an outdoor
building without insulation
yeah i would think you know uh look i
guess there's still air flow i mean
can't we just put better filtration
systems in the [ __ ] buildings
i don't know i think they're allowed to
there's a thing i think they're like
there's a lot of
companies that like can open but don't
because like you have to build negative
airflow things that are expensive like
that's
right you know a lot of people a lot of
people's jobs just are just working from
home because what we're gonna do is
spend like
10 million renovating the building right
it's like
it's um yeah i look i hear you i mean uh
are they still doing like you know do
you want the truffles only on your
macaroni when you're sitting in a shed
i mean i don't know what they're doing
they're just i mean we we had dinner at
a place tonight it was like whatever
the quality of everything here is just
no it's declined precipitously i got to
be honest with you
i mean the quality of new york city
dining is it's just dipped
and they're just slinging food to
high-end tourists even
on your way out of the city like a year
and a half two years ago yes
we were having some bad nights it was
noticeably different it was noticeably
different they're
they're just pounding money out of
foreign tourists it's not over the hood
just beating them over the head it's
expensive count money it's people that
are sprouting this throwing their
company
card out they don't they're not going
out anymore they're not saving up and
going after the special occasion that
they want to be amazing
they're just throwing corporate money at
some forgettable night they just want to
get plastered and
that's what it is and you go to a lot of
these places and you go the food is just
not really what it was i came up in the
era of 90s to new york city where it's
like
it's some of the greatest chefs that you
know now as celebrity chefs were
actually cooking in their restaurants in
the 90s that's the other problem
chefs got famous and they left their
restaurants right and now we're just
replacing them with line cooks who are
good or sous chefs
but like chefs are now running little
mini empires instead of cooking
are these is part of the problem that
the money can i imagine that
like them let's say the mad men ever in
the 60s and 70s
it was pretty easy to hide strip clubs
and [ __ ] on the company
expense account and it's you know things
have probably gotten just in general a
lot harder to do that kind of thing
later on so did that money get diverted
into restaurants is my question
that is that part of the boom in the i
don't know or or
like on the same note can we restaurants
just get you a hooker and put it on
their bill
there used to be girls that would hang
out in the big steak houses in new york
and there might still be but there were
girls that would hang out a hundred
percent they buy one
yeah can you just call it a baked potato
now you
yeah they just put it on the bill as a
baked potato a
thousand dollars you got the thousand
dollars but now it's like there's an
actual baked potato that's a thousand
dollars and there's caviar and some
garbage
certain nights girls would certainly
hang out at the things i think a lot of
the problem was it's just like
everything else it's like
chefs now run empires and they have tv
shows and they have
you know gourmet delis in addition to
their restaurants and they have outposts
in vegas and everything else
and you get to a point where the quality
ultimately suffers because it's no
longer about doing something really
unique and good
but it's about you know being this you
know massive mogul
right and you're just i mean i remember
i went to wolfgang puck's restaurant in
vegas
lupo it was so grotesque
i was embarrassed i was with this woman
i had gone out with this girl nicole
in vegas she was like we were kind of
like dating i guess years ago
years ago you know senior year of high
school 2003
and we went and we went there and the
food was so
bad and i'm just like wow wolfgang put
puck slaps his name on this but now it's
like you get it you're like oh
he's just making a shitload of money
yeah he was julia child's like weird
creepy friend right
i don't know i i think he was i'm just
saying these people
no they're shocked oh that's right
that's that creep okay
i think why is here
definitely as a seller of children oh
yeah yeah that guy's
a freak well some of these people my
name is jacques you'll learn to make a
couple good
look he put it this way i mean
zeppelin uh the who i mean the great
bands the st what are the stones doing
now where's the last time the stones act
right now
let's take them down a notch right [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up
but we're gonna like but these chefs are
gonna keep going it's like
you have a hit early on but they trade
on this name as if like their food is
like yeah you put goat cheese on a pizza
we get it right yeah
you did it you did it when
you go there i think it's low-key you go
do orleans and they come
get these [ __ ] sharp oysters and his
big and he closes up like 15 boxes like
oh it's amazing as soon as you start
telling someone you have to take a trip
there
you have to go here you have to eat it
very rarely is anything holed up
nothing is really that good in life for
the most part there are a few things
but for the most part things are pretty
good and people
try to define their lives by them and
then they tell you this is the greatest
thing i've ever had in my life well
there's nothing
there's nothing because i go to new
orleans i get the i go to desire oyster
bar
people go to act me and the desire
reservoir is a regular oyster bar in the
royal senescence hotel it is fine
the weight is a lot less you sit there
you get the grilled oysters with the
butter sauce and the bread you get the
whole hey
the whole thing is there right you want
the rolls you got and i'm sure maybe
acme is a little better
but the line and the whole thing i want
to act like it's fine it's the same
same shed you know so at the end of the
day it's like the hype
around anything yeah destroys it that's
the amazing thing about the culture that
we live in now the marketing
hype the endless marketing machine
you're not gonna have fun playing that
dobrick puzzle
you just think you are like the hype
around it destroys it how many people
you killed themselves
after losing the topic this is my last
shot
uh david dobrik dealing with bad pr as
his puzzle responsible for a rash of
suicides
that's the other thing it's like one of
these people gonna just start uploading
photos of themselves blowing their
brains out like
hey jeffree star you didn't pay my rent
well how about this
no hashtag no lambo yeah it has tag no
lambo or a guy that just blows his
brains out in the lambo
i wanted red not blue this wasn't enough
this wasn't enough it didn't fill the
hole
and by the way we're supposed to do some
show where like interview these people
like
we're supposed to do a show like david
dobrik agrees to talk with me
it is or the demilio girl is like i'm
supposed to do the show like i'm in
talks to do and i'd love to do it but
like
the idea that anyone is going to let
these social media kids anywhere near me
like if these demilitar girls who have
clothes in like every store they're like
zillionaires they own tick tock they've
got 180 million followers combined or
maybe more the if if they are in a room
with me there have been failures on
every level of their pr strategy
like that means that nobody is paying
attention like nobody's done their job
that means like you've not only breached
the white house lawn you're in the oval
office
with a loaded gun do you think someone
gets fired over the course of the end of
the season if you do this season
someone everyone if you're a pr
comp you use this as a way to get in
with them and go
dad dylan [ __ ] up i mean clean the
[ __ ] house
who is this fat [ __ ] he's got 300 000
followers
he's talking to your daughter about 9
11. your daughter's america's sweetheart
she's got [ __ ] ira postal jeans
there's [ __ ] idiots they're doing
bits about rudy giuliani
and 911 in front of your daughters did
you think that the
sisters of the 9 11 mall just
going different boutiques i mean or like
dope like there's no way in hell
dobrick's coming on a show because my
first question to him would be like
you seem to be like a willy wonka for
poor people how did this happen
how did this happen and i don't well tim
what i'd like to talk to you about
what does he like what is even his main
is like
this is all gimmicks right but what's
his main gig
he's a youtuber okay so it's just like i
just want to talk to you about my
youtube show where i
like what is even the content of though
i think he made funny cute
vine videos that people liked and now he
does you know he's putting things in his
mouth
i don't know what they do will sasso
listen every time i try to watch any of
these youtube videos it's
youtubers talking about what they're
doing and none of them are ever doing
like
they're like all right so today it's day
in the life super excited for this video
so we're waking up today now brushing my
teeth
now i have my guy now i have my
assistant
and my i'm here in a mansion my
assistant is gonna
take my dog for a walk and i'm like how
did this all start like
how do you get to mansion like every
youtuber i watch i guess i gotta go
earlier
because now they're all so famous
everything they're doing is interesting
cause they're so rich right
so you're like hey i have a golden
toilet and then that's the video
but i'm like how did this all come
together like what's the early one
show me your early work before you did
level you go well i gotta be honest with
you tim i let uh
wealthy rich men piss all over me yeah
but i don't
but i would i would i would understand
right
but no i think i think these guys are
brilliant listen
at some point on this planet
talent became offensive right i don't
know when
but at some point somebody who became
you could almost
you know maybe it was these like
american idol type shows
maybe it was something where talent
became like weird like maybe it was like
looking behind the scenes of talent
nobody wanted to do that
everybody just wanted to see judy
garland come out and sing somewhere over
the rainbow
nobody needed to know she was a pill
head in a drunk and beat her daughter
like there's a certain point when the e
true hollywood story
got too much people like you know what
enough we don't really need to see
all of the [ __ ] that went into this i i
always think about it like i'll be
laying in bed at night going
at what point do people just decide we
don't want talented people anymore
but it happened right at a certain point
people go we don't want
any van halen yeah yeah you show boaty
yeah
just [ __ ] it wasn't music anymore
like
this is too fast you didn't like it
it was coked out and it finally came too
and was like enough we'll just
we'll have a hoodie but at some point i
maybe with susan boyle when she came out
it was like this ugly woman who sang
she's so talented we don't care doesn't
he just melted everyone's head they're
like we don't want any
i don't know when it was but at a
certain point people like we don't
want to so what they wanted was like
this relatability
make me feel comfortable shane dawson
like
not great looking decent looking not
like not
not horrific looking but like very
average across-the-board guy
not that funny not that talented but
was open and let you see everything
about his life
and and you they were selling access to
their lives and all of their thoughts
and all of their feelings and
and how they interacted with the world
and i guess that's
what people at a certain point that's
what people started to find interesting
they're like
i just want a friend i don't want
somebody's talent i don't know when that
happened
and not to take anything away from these
people right not taking anything away
from dobrik i'm sure there are talents
there you don't get
that big with that certain kind of
talent but i think the main thing
was that these people just had a real
insatiable need to post their lives
online and the people
connected with i think it's also look
they're proud of the time but i think
that
it wouldn't exist if it wasn't for the
weird appetite on the people
well of course and like it's like at
some point you could your dad couldn't
yell at you
he couldn't make you feel stupid and
like it was like everything had to be
softened like i'm not
playing i'm not trying to say oh nerf
the world everyone i'm not in cell
but i'm just saying but there was a
certain point where like you had to kind
of take it on the chin a little bit
right and like these kids don't it's
like it's like a variation of the whole
you know participation trophy horseshit
whatever you want to call it
and so like this cuddle this content
never would have worked when we were
kids i mean we would have uh
no it's it's coddling but it's something
deeper than that something strange
i don't know what it is i i think about
it all the time it's not
simply that um i think that plays a part
in it that sets a
cultural 100 tone but there's something
that there's something going on
where people are watching other people
open gifts that they didn't get
right there's something going on where
people are watching
someone eat food like a mukbang just
gorge themselves with food and they
don't care about
literature they don't care about movies
they don't really music is whatever
but like they're they're they're passing
your time
by watching someone gorge themselves
with
large quantities of food and i don't
know if it's
sexual if it's a repressed desire
i don't know what deep dark weird [ __ ]
is going on in our minds
that this type of content is appealing
to people but it really
is appealing to people it's like a
blanket a mukbang is a blanket
is it i don't i never got into them are
they good they're not cool look here's
the thing about mukbangs at least the
ones i've watched
is they're done by these guys like
stoney shout out to stoney he was just a
small guy who's a competitive eater
stoney from the long island comedy scene
i don't think so i think he's just some
dude he was like
people pound like like a hundred [ __ ]
used to do a ton of them oh really yeah
yeah he just got one like he's one of
the he competes in the coney island
i'm just saying like it's not so it's
not it's the guy doing it doesn't seem
sad he's a skinny guy
he's doing it competitively
quote-unquote whatever whatever that
means you know what his life is like
but i mean it's a whole but the person
watching it
is some like either fat person or like a
person who
is fat at heart and they like it's the
lack of uh
filter it's like it's like you know when
they go to mcdonald's i can only have
if i even go i have one big mac maybe
two but this guy just
it's the lack of no one's telling them
no and it's that
there's a deep something's happening
where it's like we're allowed to see
this now and i think maybe before
we weren't allowed to see it you know
there wasn't this community of people
there wasn't this
platform to view this stuff i mean a lot
of it's sec like the asmr is sexual for
people
the sounds the feelings the way they
feel
i mean i feel weird sometimes when i
hear them but i don't know if it's
sexual
like but i feel like a weird chill
sensation
whatever people claim or like however
many people claim it
as a dominant asmr i i think it's like
one percent of them
are actually like it's one of those
things where it's like people like look
it sounds pleasant right it's not like
you're you're [ __ ] playing with like
you know razors in your hands you're
cutting your hands going no it's just
weird but i like this
no it's a pleasant thing they go this
does it for me people don't understand
people
self-diagnosing themselves well
tick-tock is fascinating right because
tick tock seems to be divided into
two camps you have the the cringy tick
tock where it's just crazy people doing
[ __ ] right
and then you have like the young hot
kids dancing and mirrors right i mean
we understand that like that's just kind
of a rebranding of teenie but
here's my thing culture now
seems more than ever generated or
determined by 12 year old girls
like that's what's very interesting to
me some of the beatles
no yeah no no of course of course
so what the [ __ ] wrong with our 12
year old girl that's michael yeah that's
that's
that's my question that's the
interesting question that's the question
yes yeah
because to be from the beatles to
somebody dancing in a house when did
kids have
getting such low standards yeah exactly
and was it really 12 year old girls that
like the beatles or they're a little
older but i get what you mean
you're not contingent of that you're not
wrong it is that's what i mean like
the culture like adults seem to don't
really
determine much of the culture no i mean
it was like something they do it was
like velvet underground which was like
intellectual but no one was
chasing them down the airport but i mean
like the people right now in their 30s
what are they determined i guess
podcasts
i guess that's the mma stuff the [ __ ]
you know who's watching
right you know supplements and the you
know whatever and like the
the weird political discourse you know
snbc that goes nowhere
that's look is it anything better
today is that even better than the
[ __ ] kids dancing in the mirror i
think that's a pro the problem is
the futility that is out there like
like there really is no hope right like
i don't i think
even it's a new theme for the tim dillon
show everybody
we're breaking new ground it's another
tell them what they've won
it's another there is no hope no but i
really feel like dude like it's just
apparent that even
the least illegal people that like oh
yeah like people have been talking about
how screwed
up this this whole system is for decades
now and nothing changes
we have we held obama who seems like he
would be the guy who would change it he
didn't change
like it's even they don't understand why
or how or they don't understand the
power structure per se but like
they get that they're like oh it's all
kind of fake it gets more fake every
year
and so it breaks the brain in a certain
way where like you don't like why would
you care about
right like you know some guy who's just
you know part of the record company
industry it's all
well something happened to me i bought
that dumb vape hoodie for the
sketch i did where i played the rapper
was not a rapper what was i playing
an influencer right and i put the hoodie
on
i'm in the babe store and you know
nobody treats you nice as a plus-sized
man by buying clothes
unless you're in the baby store and you
have lovely black man came up to me he
goes you you look fresh as [ __ ] right
now and i was like
thank you that's the first comment i'd
ever gotten in a clothing store
and i put that hoodie on and i look
ridiculous right i look like a candy
cane and got my red sweats
and i and i something happened to me as
soon as i put the hoodie on like i
didn't
i was like i still haven't i'm still
gonna wear it occasionally sure
i i put it on i started saying life is
meaningless
but why not like look like a ridiculous
person
and walk down the street and be a
hypebeat like i almost understood
hypebeasts
right because i'm like oh here's a
community that i'm now a part of
i wasn't a part of it then i just put on
this dumb sweatshirt and some guy's like
you look good
i'm like i could have started talking to
him i could have been like what are you
getting what are you thinking about
who's got what drop and you're like oh i
kind of understand
why you know that culture is appealing
to people
the uh the alternative is the same
you'll turn them right
no i i will find out who did 9 11.
i don't care how many decades it takes i
love that's the world that we've decided
it's
hypebeast or who did 9 11 like those are
your two choices like
being ready like all right kids so you
could grow up to be a hypebeast or you
could launch an investigation into 9 11.
your choice but that's the oldest
difference
the alternative is i'm going to fix it
or i'm going to buy this hoodie right
so that's the thing because there is
like at a certain point
it's not even giving up on the
conspiracy thing because like at a
certain point did they figure out that
if you can kind of create a binary
that like goods things change in this
country you know in the first half of
the 20th century and like in the 60s and
70s they got real change done to a
certain extent
and i think but it was like slower it's
incremental people like you know didn't
make it it wasn't like kind of led by
it was you know a lot of like lawyers
gave up their time and like and then
and people were activists for years you
know it was like and now it just seems
much more like
all at once and you fizzle out and you
lose and then just kind of
you don't have the in-between of just
kind of it's normal it's normal that we
all kind of
like patiently work for things no it's
just like everything or nothing
so it's like yeah it's just how they
keep a grip
it's like yeah if you want to be a you
know go
you you can go on you know in public and
be a [ __ ] you know you can kind of be a
loud mouthpiece for a while but it's not
going to sustain the world is so
ridiculous when i put on that hoodie i'm
like oh well i'm just taking my place
in insanity now yeah in the way in a way
that i kind of like
understood and it resonated with me
immediately because i'm like
you know you're listening to the motto
talking this [ __ ] sucker just crook this
[ __ ] truly high
this [ __ ] and you realize that
really
is what it is like you know trump
doesn't pay anybody i'm bad and he's a
[ __ ] crook like
and you're like oh there's that which is
kind of the way it is
and that you could either live in that
and
god bless you try to wade through those
murky waters and keep your soul god love
you
or you could just kind of buy a
ridiculous hoodie i mean how many people
are even capable like people this is
myth that like life is more than
the nice meals and the cigars and the
women and the men and whatever the [ __ ]
it is
the sensory things that like even if you
are
jimmy page or whoever like david bowie i
mean how much more satisfied is david
bowie
i'm sure he's a little he's something
more to look at i mean of course he's
more accomplished
than but like how much happier or even
just if you're not happy it's
like how much more like fulfilled is he
i don't even know like
people are often like kind of unhappy uh
i guess
people that feel you know when you think
about honor and bravery and risk and all
these great
virtue and all these things that life is
supposed to be about but then you go in
in the world that we've created you know
i'm not saying it's impossible to
display those virtues
i'm sure there are ways to do it doesn't
help when veterans like can't get health
care
right right you owe me a wheelchair why
can't your wall yeah what happened to
your leg
i mean like it's just like it's
subliminally like
there is and then you have like tina 40
my favorite out there [ __ ] trump
2020 [ __ ]
she's my favorite person because like
she's just selling stop to steal hats
and trump forever socks and like
she's just like go to my online store
everyone's got an online store
like i get it but i mean that's why it's
like my thing i'm like i do a podcast i
think it's funny
buy the merch we come up with funny
merch [ __ ] like that but like
i'm never gonna tell you like hey guys
it's gonna be okay
and it and here's why it's gonna be okay
because you're gonna go to the online
store
like the tina tina's 40s like her like
everything dovetails together it's like
go to the online store the revolution's
here we're packing the streets
we're going to every state capital trump
2020 [ __ ]
i'm like there's no there is no trump
2020 was the whole trump thing just an
excuse to sell hats
well i have to talk about that if like a
few billion selling those hats
maybe the whole thing's merged what if
the entire trump presidency was a merge
operation just a crazy merch operation
like he should
he showed nelk he's like i'm the
granddaddy of merch
imagine this you make a list of the
gifts you're gonna buy for the holidays
and then someone randomly gives you the
money to help buy one sound good
well that's what honey is doing they're
helping pay for one million dollars
worth of gifts
you're probably wondering is this the
same honey that automatically searches
for promo codes online yes yes it is
with honey you can also make a list of
all the holiday gifts you want from
certain stores
and honey will email you when the price
drops on anything on your list that's
really cool
just add honey to your computer create a
free online account and throw some
holiday gifts on your drop list
for a chance to win honey will randomly
select winners and give them the money
to help buy something on their list i'm
going to
[Music]
have honey help me pay for a lot of
gifts
there's gifts that i'm going to give you
and that i want honey to pay for no
purchase necessary you need a paypal
account to redeem the prize
only valid in the us giveaway ends 12 21
20 20. okay go to honey get honey for
free at jointhoney.com
tim dillon my favorite thing about this
there's a million things about it but it
is really cool
you make a list when prices drop they'll
let you know that is awesome
that is really really great so go to
honey for free join honey dot com slash
tim dillon that's join honey dot com
slash tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
what do you think about that spoon what
do you think about that
spoon that magic spoon
new year's is coming up you know it's
coming up you know what's coming out
there
you know what's coming up you know it's
coming you know what it is
new year's resolutions changes in the
air 2020 was a [ __ ]
2021 is going to be a lot better
okay magicspoon.com tim dillon you know
what it is 0
grams of sugar 11 grams of protein three
net grams of carbs in each serving
okay you can build your own custom
variety box
this cereal is keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low carb
gmo free i love magic spoon the fruity
flavor
tastes exactly like froot loops it's
really amazing
it's honestly too good to be true it's a
great snack
if you're on a low carb meal plan it
gets rid of a a snack
or a meal perfect really good
great people love the breakfast routine
some people love cereal
um i love cereal
why are you shaking your head oh i was
like i love it so much too
like you know why aren't you dressed
like i'm dressed
well i got the adidas on shut up
you understand that i show up ready to
work
and you look like [ __ ] and that's going
to be a problem
if it's not remedied we're going to have
a problem
magicspoon.com tim dillon to build your
own custom variety box
and try it today magicspoon.com
tim dillon to build your own custom
variety box it's great
cereal it's a great way to support our
show it's a great way to support your
body
and immune health right yeah yeah you
don't want
a lot of sugar in your diet bad for your
immune system
i just don't understand why you would
come to work looking so ridiculous
i don't i personally don't understand it
but i understand it
you feel that you're not taking it
seriously
and we have a new studio and i want you
to start to take it seriously
that's all
that's what i'm saying do you understand
that i understand
magicspoon.com
tim dillon right
magicspoon.com slash tim dillon
and use the code you get free shipping
use the code tim dillon good for them
what is his post-presidency look like if
you could guess ah
i mean you gotta look you buy into this
[ __ ] he's gonna be like this big you
know figurehead in the republican party
i don't know
what no he look he might still run
for years he's crazy enough he might but
either way he's either gonna live in
trump tower
or he might i don't wanna like fall for
like the the griff that like oh they're
gonna actually arrest them and do all
this [ __ ]
but they might and like he might be
smart to get out of here and go like to
somewhere
with you know less extradition i don't
think he's gonna do that i don't think
biden
wants that and i also don't think i mean
i i don't think they're gonna do that i
think that
i think he decompresses
yeah sobers up not from booze he doesn't
drink or any of that but i think sober's
up from the idea like
i'll probably move permanently to
mar-a-lago i think i'll move probably to
marlock i think what'll kill him is
not going to those rallies i think those
rallies were everything they were
they've never had that before
he never had those rounds no he's like
it seemed like he was always a grifter
and like a car he became a god yeah
but he never had the like in person like
[ __ ] like the crowd
well he never became a god and you know
me and you touched on this
years ago the the greatest thing about
trump i think or the the magic was the
implausible becoming the plausible right
the idea that he was winning
the idea that he won the idea that he
was the president
it's a fairy tale right it's a fairy
tale it's an american fairy tale
right now when a guy like him
is not the president yeah it's almost
like what are we doing
you know you seem more and more like a
crank
and it's not fun yeah because the crank
is no longer the president
like you're just a guy yelling oh yeah
and people are kind of going to be like
how are we going to be invested in this
because there's
you know well like i don't think he does
trump tv
i don't think he does he does think he's
running in 2024. he does think that he's
not gonna but
he thinks it now i mean like he'll
probably be dead by then like he's gonna
look he i really do feel like he he
what's keeping him going is like
adrenaline and like he's taking a lot of
bad roll
allegedly uh and look i'm just saying
like he doesn't seem
if troll if trump we've always
remembered how like some of these guys
these deep state guys always seem to
live and like well they eat the good
food and they take care of themselves
and then we have a guy like this who's
just eating trash every day he's just
taking drugs though it's like but maybe
it's the greatest drug is narcissism
like we realize
maybe we realize that's the ultimate
survival nobody wants to hear that right
but the ultimate survival mechanism is
to just be a soulless narcissist for
your entire life
you know like that's just gripping to
life that's the way to survive
everything from coven to [ __ ]
everything he's just gonna
he's gonna get feather right uh he's
gonna play golf every day
like it's not gonna be remarkable he's
gonna play golf and get fat
uh fire off a tweet every now and then
he'll probably tweet all the time he'll
probably be cranked out
yeah and people are gonna ignore him now
yeah it's just gonna be
like we're gonna remark how
we're gonna at one point say wow we
underestimated how much damage he could
still do
well let's just say that at some point
yeah i mean because he will do he will
cause something to happen i mean maybe
i don't know i'm really wondering what's
what's that still from i don't know
these are
my work makes me have them the butcher
shop i work at oh yeah
screen savers on my computer i mean
i just don't know but you know
biden and kamala man they're gonna
i mean they're gonna put people in jail
you think oh
i don't know what they'll do i think
we'll probably go to getting into a war
soon
we might need that you know we need that
we're not getting out of this economic
thing without a few little skirmishes
that's but here's the problem we don't
get out of a war that's the myth and
it's not i'm not sure what the henry
haslam like broken window fallacy yeah
that's a different thing
we've had perpetual war for like 60
years now 75 years
you don't get like it doesn't really
juke the economy anymore like it worked
in world war ii because we didn't have
all the stuff
right we had to build it now we like we
keep it it does juice economy for
certain sects or something right so
i mean look here's the thing we have
it's kind of getting it backwards
the economy is set in such a way where
you have to fight wars every 10 years or
so just to deplete the stock
pile so that you can the these companies
who run the economy this is why
that's what i mean we got it you got to
you got to play that's just to keep the
status quo
you got it it's reverse it's reversed
you gotta play to pay
it's not pay-to-play you gotta play to
pay
and i think we gotta play a little bit
so we can pay later i mean i don't know
but
that's just to keep that sector from
imploding that's not even to get like
going
how do you feel you'll get old i thought
about this the other day do you go to
the woods do
you know i was thinking about this the
other day and i go how am i going to get
old
i'm an eagle scout so i'll go to the
woods yeah do you ever think to yourself
like getting a nice house in a wood like
oh sure i would love to have an upstate
new york or
right you know somewhere like vermont i
mean a little call i mean i prefer
something
super cold but you know me and ben got
to decide where we're gonna go if we're
gonna stay in la go to texas wherever
we're gonna go
that's gonna be nice i mean like i'd
like to start hunting yeah um
we're just having like i would like to
do more [ __ ] in nature i would like to
get out of
uh like i'm in new york for the last
couple of days man i love new york to
death but like
i walk around the city and i go there's
no part of me that could even ever
consider living here again
sure can you use i look at these people
running down the streets and coats and
hats i mean i'm like god
it's whatever this was it felt it i'm
done with this place in
in every way you can work as omni
corporal
but when you're hunting out there in the
mentality can you draw grenades with
deers
yes that seems fun yeah i might want to
do that
i would like i would like to use a like
a grenade launcher yeah
so we could kind of really get some
cover some ground can you shoot a deal
with a potato gun
in the head like it would kill him
probably right your potato goodness i
don't think there's much you can't do to
i think if you want to [ __ ] a deer to
death you could i don't know if i have
the
stamina for that might need to i think
dude what if you went on rogan and
that's all you asked right
you're like can you shoot a deal with a
potato gun jump i don't think so man
what happened i think i don't know ma'am
you know think about
dears ma'am you're gonna hurt them but
they're very strong animals
and uh what if i made it eat a rock
would it die
wait the problem is you can't get near
the map you can't get near the map
it's very tough so i don't bring
marshall into the woods because it's
very hard ma'am can't get in your eyes
and it's fascinating you can't really
get near them so i mean i think what you
would have to do
you said on fire maybe can you set a
deer on fire well there's definitely
local laws
that will prevent that man if there's
definitely
laws that are you know specific to each
region they're going to prevent that
activity because what they want to do is
create um
you know a kind of a safe environment
for hunters to keep these animal
populations thriving so let me ask you a
question have you been out there let me
ask you a question
you're you're incredibly fat man have
you ever thought of
getting on a ketogenic diet doing very
high protein low carb low sugar
you know start doing interval training
you know kind of building muscle doing a
lot of cardio heavy cardio
things like that no uh not really
now let me ask you when you go out in
the woods and you see one of these do
you ever say
i hate this particular deer i hate it i
want to die
i think emotion is a huge problem when
you're in that situation
and what you have to really do is
remember uh the mechanics of what you're
doing
and i think anybody that gets too
emotional right ma'am
it's a bad that's a better demo because
what really happens
is it just clouds your you think i can
still do the show after i've done this
imitation it's not even a good
invitation
you think you think you think you think
i'm allowed to do the show now
i don't know ray kump it's always great
to have you on we're going to try to do
a new year's livestream you're still
down to come out oh yeah
yeah definitely we don't know how we're
gonna do it
we're trying to figure that out it's
difficult uh we may just end up doing it
on youtube
um i think we'll probably do something
like that i think
at this mo i don't want to hit people
over the head for more money
right now because we just did merch and
people supported that and i appreciate
that
and people support us on patreon all the
time support comp on patreon too
we'll play we'll put his links in the
description about the help thank you
but i i which he doesn't he's i'm
sitting right now he's a
massive he's not man it's a small person
kidding well
no one thought it was massive no one
thought i wasn't doing it i'm not rich
yeah no one thought i wasn't doing it
bad no one was like i
knew it nobody thought you were living
in the the money the
vault from ducktales um
i can't i can't reach the top drowning
in the goal yeah i was like you would
launch pad mcquack are doing backstroke
and gold coins
but i think we might just do a youtube
you know two two and a half hour
livestream on new year's eve and then
maybe we'll turn on some super chats
maybe
people could throw us some money but i
just do i want to kind of
give people a break it's been a shitty
year it's been very hard there's a lot
of people out there that don't have
money and i just don't want
i don't want to like [ __ ] ask people
to pay i think if people don't have any
[ __ ] money
and everything that we do in the future
by the way it's like even if we do do
any of these live events with tickets
we're also going to have a situation
where
if you don't have the money you can
email
and watch it for free you know which is
the right thing
you know but i mean my agent told me
that he goes
we gotta he goes sam harris does it like
this we're like his fans if
they can't afford it there's an email
and i go listen
you know how many people are gonna do
that
i'm looking at you like what are we
doing here my fans will do that for the
sake of doing it
they'll be like yeah doing some fake
business um
but yeah i mean i think we're gonna go
that route of the last it's just too
complex to get anything else ready but i
do think we're eventually going to start
you know put together a platform where
we can do you know ticketed events kind
of like segura bird are doing what we
could do with three other thing that i
hate about youtube is
that we can't stream what we want in
terms like we can't play clips from
things
can't play any music or really clips
from pop
pop culture [ __ ] or any other
youtube channel but i think on certain
platforms you can do all of that stuff
but it costs a lot of money to build out
those platforms or whatever
set them up so you do you know you
charge people it is what it is people
buy a ticket and then they get like a
three hour
no holds bar completely uncensored live
stream where we could play any clip
do anything talk about it and it makes a
lot of sense i just don't know if we're
going to have that together by
new year's i imagine we're not so
imagine we're just going to kind of have
to do it on youtube and deal with the
content restrictions
okay yeah we should be playing anyway
we always say we're going to play clips
and we play like a minute well we could
i think it'd be really fun to play a
certain thing oh eventually we'll do it
but i'm saying like
we'll we'll still be good without the
clips that would be great without what
are you doing on new year's eve anyway
folks who are you gonna watch
oh i was gonna i was gonna sign for tim
and ray but uh no they can't play
you know the bieber what are you gonna
play they can't
play
can you imagine we do have one fan
that's like totally like
we always think about great characters
like hypebeast chris hedges
like a guy that he's like our corporate
overlords but he loves sneakers
like he's a hypebeast he realizes
everything's [ __ ] and why he's like
the oligarchy and the plutocrats but he
just loves sneakers and hoodies he's a
fresh
yeah he's fresh he's like i just look so
goddamn fresh
he's like i know i'm i'm serving the
plutocrats and the oligarchs that have
hollowed out all of our institutions
but i look so fresh um
but um yeah but what are you gonna do
play the dobrik puzzle on new year's
you're gonna want you're gonna
you're not going out you're gonna need
to [ __ ] do something cool we'll just
get some kid whose dad
is no longer with us because there's no
big puzzle
what what was your last memories of your
dad you were
playing the puzzle did your dad win
he didn't win what was his last
he fired off one final tweet to jeffree
star
said favorite distance give me money
dude should i start tweeting to jeffree
star like under dummy accounts like
horrific things like hi jeffrey
i was raped when i was nine years old
the trauma of that has just made me
unable to
you know i worked at a factory i lost my
arm
do i get a car what did you see if he'll
give me five grand
okay
i was ripped by a bunch of animals uh
literal deers
that's money i mean like it's just funny
because like jeffree star looks at those
things he's like yeah i don't know that
doesn't really
but i think that doesn't speak to me
your tragedy doesn't speak to me today
isn't like a makeup guy yeah they're all
makeup guys everybody's a makeup guy
everybody's selling [ __ ] makeup man
it's amazing you know
we've talked about it on the show before
that i could use some makeup
tell the people where they can find if
they want to find you and they haven't
found you already
you need to listen to the comp podcast
it's become a
a it's getting a much bigger following
people are loving it it's grown into
something it's you know
a slightly rocky start but it's grown
through a really great absurd
this is the point the judge goes sir
there's a missing woman
there's a missing woman and there's
physical evidence connecting you to her
disappearance
listen this podcast has become a
linchpin of
satirical sir once again
listen to me the comp podcast so tell
them about comp and then our love is
disgusting
all i was discussing also with lucy
steiner there's something out out there
like this i mean tim's got a great thing
going
it's true i do something different
that's great uh also great
um but it's it's very funny it's on
different frequencies
camera's got a good thing going but he
doesn't have any love in his life
so he doesn't think he can't even have
love even if it's disgusting he doesn't
have it
but uh yeah you stop at the comp patreon
uh patreon.com
uh merch i am a wine princess [ __ ] i am
a wine princess [ __ ]
shirts available in crew sweatshirts and
t-shirts all that stuff
people love them for your i mean it's
it's a wine bottle with a machete
and it's just your wife loves it i
should get her
her own shirt for that
i should get it her own shirt you keep
your hands off this woman i don't know
if like she wants a more form-fitting
yeah will you leave her form out what do
you think should i
come over here we measure her
listen would your wife sit on me
maybe she should poop on me
so yeah twitter instagram raycomp uh
yeah
you know there's a whole world of comp
out there come join
come join the world of
comp yeah i mean what do we have to plug
ben do we have anything
patreon.com tim dylan show for uh
additional bonus content uh
uh the merch is closed we appreciate
that we'll be back in maybe the spring
we'll do a drop we have some cool ideas
cool designs [ __ ] like that
new studio being designed we do
apologize that this is another non-video
episode
our next episode will be video from our
new studio will our sign be ready
so well that's going to be a new episode
from our new studio very excited about
that that was just built
and designed and this is our episode
from new york city with ray kump
in brooklyn parting thoughts closing
words
what are you telling people the holidays
are coming up right you'll be around for
new year's you could give them some
thoughts on that but
i mean for the for the christmas holiday
what what what are you telling the
people for the hanukkah and the kwanzaa
stop looking for meaning in
corporate entertainment and and
corporate sex
you know these corporate models find
someone who will touch you
willingly uh and just caress them
and sing to them let them sing to you uh
like me
but you'll be my shirts this is
beautiful buy merch if you want if that
fulfills you but just
find out who you are at your core and
then just you know as
gross as it may be you don't have there
is there's no more
the patina is gone you don't have to
hold yourself towards there's no don
draper
there's no tom cruise you know tom
cruise is screaming at some guy because
he's you know not wearing a mask
on the submission impossible just be who
you are eat buffalo wings
you know yell at your kid uh and just
you know like love your wife
love your husband who gives a [ __ ] will
you instruct a defender to answer the
question when he saw
when he last saw the victim alive when
did he last
see the victim alive you can stop all
the talk about the patina
and everything going on when did you
last see
the victim alive was she in your car
the advice of counselor
but then just start going right back
who we are is so important francis scott
key once said
you know it's interesting we've never
been to jail i've never been to like
i've never gone to prison
uh like you as the prisoner you mean
you're just busy i've never been
in no i've been in a jail i've been in a
cell because since my license
but like there's got to be something
interesting about doing doing time in
prison i don't want to i don't want to
do it
i mean i've had like i spent you know a
day you know the better of a day in
prison
or jail and you you get a taste of that
i don't know no
it's just it's kind of crazy how it's
something where
like you spend your whole life thinking
of it it's something that's always in
your head even though like we
like privilege and all that we didn't
have to but like it's still it's
something that hangs over your head and
then when you're actually there though
there's something about the like
the tedium of that day it's like oh this
must be the worst thing in the world for
like for
you know two years if you're there for
you know prison is my point
is it no i know i don't know where i was
going with that
i'm just i just tried to like her work
out ideas and i thought maybe
i just can't you think maybe you'd like
to go to prison is that your point no i
just think that like
white women will eventually start going
on vacations and prisons like they'll
make angola into like a bed and
breakfast
and they're like people just have like
you'll be eating it like you know
you know i've talked about this before
in the show but like there's definitely
gonna be a time when they like
like dead the the the electric chairs
like people doing selfies in it and like
you know
well they did that in albatros prisoners
yeah they did that absolutely
prison is so weirdly inhumane obviously
you need prisons
but like it's just one of these archaic
things where
you know it really does just destroy
people
oh yeah look it's just you you need them
for a certain percentage of the
population
which is a fraction of what it is now
like i mean like it's just
it's so obviously like it's it's run for
profit it's run
like you know this lobby is to keep
certain laws in place to keep certain
people in the pro it's not
not just the private prisons it's just a
whole is a huge racket
um it's just another you know segment of
the economy and
the government in the middle like like
the military like you know it's like
once the military industrial complex
became a thing then you had to find a
reason to fight wars and
once the prison thing came out you had
to find reason to keep you know people
in prison
it's just you know and like the the
police uh guard lobbies were like lobby
against like you know pot smoking being
legal
there's no even like yeah there's no
correlation other than you want more
prisoners
right i love that the the
the what is it the corrections officers
will be like we want we don't want poppy
illegal
right yeah it's just literally like the
only argument you can make it's like
well there's gonna be less
you know jobs for us it's just every few
years the pope
uh sends people did you see the people
liked it instagram
like he likes some chicken only fans or
something some instagram yeah yeah
yeah he's looking kind of trouble why
does he even have an actual like account
oh no dude there's something happening
the pope uses the pope account
this is a total fake story the pope
liked a
girl on instagram or something there's
probably honestly some dude who
runs the pope's account who also has
another thing on his phone
and he flips the profile right because
i'm just saying i just don't imagine the
pope
being allowed to use that i don't think
pub dates women
or you know yeah yeah that pope is uh
there's so much about how good of a guy
he is that's why i think the pubs like
little hoodie
but the poke the vacuum would send what
if the little puddle
started dating the pope
yeah the pope liked and only fans bikini
fan yeah
i don't think the the poe by the way
here's what's crazy
that's the healthiest thing that's ever
happened to the catholic church
what's about to come out about the pope
yeah how many he's a heterosexual that
likes
women like that's that's the healthiest
thing that catholic church has ever had
uh this whole school is about the
whistleblower on the pope all right
go like some you know pamela anderson
yeah yeah go like some yeah imagine that
right
that's so funny yeah uh this pope is
involved in this horrible rape scandal
with this uh
girls school in sierra leone it's like
hey man just go like a couple of some
gash on instagram i love belladonna yeah
she really gapes
yeah throw moss is set what's the pulp's
name
pope francis you gotta throw him off the
scent
go like bella thorne's [ __ ] bikini
picture right now
throw him off the set so when these 19
kids come out
and say they've witnessed you [ __ ]
sacrificing their friends
you have a [ __ ] alibi like the pope's
like i'm just a man trying to get my
dick wet
you know help me you know how to be
i think the thousands on the holy ghost
would it be great if that was the pope's
instagram like you know how it'd be
dude what about hypebeast pope he just
starts coming out like bathing ape like
pulp clothes
he's like man he's like listen he's like
i believe the salvation then i put that
[ __ ] painting a booty on
and i just said to myself dude what a
great
futuristic novel where the pope is just
a hypebeast walking around los
angeles just drugged out of his head
like that's like a brilliant novel that
would win a pulitzer like
the pope like like 200 years in the
future the pope but not even like
10 10 years in the future let me calm
that down
four years in the future the pope is a
high
piece just walking around los angeles
getting high with a cannabis company
all right everybody thank you for
listening you guys are the best we
appreciate you and have a great holiday
and play that dobrick puzzle